[Aplausos]
[Música]
en alguna ocasión han hecho un recorrido
consciente por la ciudad
no de manera sistemática ni rutinaria
sino conscientes y analíticos de lo que
hay a nuestro alrededor
me ha pasado constantemente y yo creo
que ustedes también y mientras vas a tu
destino te pierdes en tus pensamientos
en lo que vas a ser una vez que llegas
en los pendientes que traes en la
plática en el coche o en la música y
cuando menos te diste cuenta y llegaste
a tu destino
me han pasado que me ha asustado y
pareciera que de manera sistemática
llegué
y con el miedo de tener o provocar algún
accidente decidí cambiar completamente
esa dinámica
decidí ser más observador y no volver a
viajar a la deriva
caminando o recorriendo y ahora
observando la ciudad te das cuenta de
cuántos vacíos existen cuántas áreas sin
desarrollar cuantos parques sucios y
pareciera que el tirar basura en algún
punto se convirtiera en un punto de
acopio de residuos o aumentar una raya
en una pared pareciera que es una señal
de es un lienzo en blanco
y percibimos de ello existe un estudio
llamado los vidrios rotos un estudio que
desarrolló la universidad de stanford en
el 69 un estudio que constaba de dos
vehículos
efecto en cadena que se da a partir del
primer acto a partir de romper un
cristal el primer vehículo a partir del
primer acto de rock en una serie de
desmantelamientos el segundo que
permanecía intacto de manera consciente
decidieron romper un cristal esto en
automático lanzó una señal de el resto
te toca a ti
y les pregunto a qué se debe
qué pasa cuando las ciudades
no se desarrollan qué pasa cuando un
parque se mantiene sucio que percibimos
de ello
exacto un efecto dominó un efecto en
cadena la pintura es el arte
y la técnica para pensar imaginar y
construir espacios habitables espacios
que sean refugios espacios funcionales y
estéticos
espacio para esparcimiento para la
convivencia espacios para el estudio
qué pasa cuando las ciudades
no se desarrollan qué pasa cuando las
ciudades
demuestran esas deficiencias
una reacción en cadena que lleva a una
ciudad a la decadencia el ejemplo de
ello pudiera ser ciudad juárez una
ciudad fronteriza ubicada al norte de
méxico una de las fronteras más grandes
del país
una ciudad fronteriza que su dinámica
parte de lo que conlleva
el compartir territorio con una de las
potencias más grandes del mundo
una ciudad que ha tenido un crecimiento
desmedido un crecimiento desordenado muy
expande expandido muy horizontal
una ciudad que ha sido duramente
golpeada por la violencia pero que a
pesar de ello y por su gente ha sabido
sobrellevar lo ha sabido saber mira
adelante y se ha convertido en esta
ciudad resiliente
cuando el estudiante de arquitectura
tuve esa oportunidad de ir a este
congreso de arquitectura en la ciudad de
mexico
ese momento para mí fue un parteaguas un
momento que marcó con la diferencia mi
desarrollo personal y profesional ese
momento cuando te encuentras contigo
mismo y decides esto es lo que quiero
hacer el resto de mi vida
una vez estando en estos congresos me
vino este cuestionamiento es lo que
tengo aquí que es lo que hace que esta
experiencia sea tan diferente que es lo
que estoy viviendo en este espacio que
no encuentro en mi ciudad porque este
ambiente es tan estimulante
qué tengo que hacer yo para lograr ese
mismo ambiente
ahora les pregunto no es algo que todos
estemos buscando
tener estos espacios ideales esta ciudad
sin vidrios rotos esta ciudad que nos
motive que nos inspiren ese espacio que
nos rodea y que nos ayude a colaborar
que favorezca las dinámicas sociales que
permita que nos unamos como comunidad
una vez que terminé mi carrera como a
muchos me despertó esa idea de irme a
vivir a otro lado de desarrollarme
profesionalmente en alguna de estas
grandes metrópolis donde aparentemente
ya todo estaba hecho
y acoplarse a las dinámicas disfrutar y
ser parte de
pero recorre esa ciudad en la que vivo
ese diamante en bruto en donde había
mucho por hacer gracias a dios en el
camino he tenido la fortuna de toparme
con aquellas personas con quien puedo
hoy si tienen ideales en valores en
principios en metas he tenido la
posibilidad de colaborar con gente que
tiene las mismas coincidencias por lo
que aunque yo tuve
estos tiempos de pandemia que han sido
tiempos difíciles tipos de reflexión
tiempos para detenernos y pensar como
hemos hecho las cosas y cómo las vamos a
hacer ha sido tiempo muy duro tiempo de
valorar tiempo de vivir cosas que nunca
habíamos estado preparados para ello
pero sobre todo fueron tiempos de
planeación tiempos de ver que viene
adelante
ahora que sé hacer arquitectura
pospandemia las dinámicas han cambiado
que como convivimos los espacios que
ocupamos
el cómo
nuestro refugio en nuestros hogares se
convierten en esos nuevos templos que
hay que cuidar y que hay que evitar que
nos invadan la arquitectura que se ha
tenido que reprogramar sus programas
mismos han tenido que cambiar
y mi reflexión es la siguiente
hagamos ciudad recuperemos aquellos
vacíos
recuperemos aquellos aquellas áreas que
no se han desarrollado
y han sido abandonadas aquellos espacios
que han permitido que su entorno
inmediato haya caído
y un ejemplo de ello
es el consulado americano un espacio que
se diseñó y que fue pensado
originalmente para ser un espacio
oficial en un espacio para trámites
migratorios cuando murieron sucede la
zona se decayó completamente tener la
oportunidad de intervenirlo de
transformarlo este espacio inspirador
ese espacio en donde las dinámicas
cambiaron transformarlo en el parque de
innovación emprendimiento más grande de
la frontera estos espacios que fomenten
la colaboración
pareciera que es regresar a los
fundamentos
aquellos espacios flexibles dinámicos
espacios ventilados espacio con buena
iluminación
y recuperar espacios el crear nuevos
centros urbanos tiene que ver con
repensar la arquitectura
rescatar
y reutilizar los elementos como pensar
en convertir unos contenedores marítimos
un espacio un bloque contenedor de ideas
un espacio que nuevamente fomente el
trabajo colaborativo un espacio flexible
que hable y dialogue de lo que es la
ciudad
y pensar que estas piezas de contenedor
fueron originalmente
diseñados para trasladar mercancías
durante largos recorridos refugiados y
que ahora sean parte de un proyecto
arquitectónico
de reflexión finales apropien unos de
los espacios
los espacios que puede permitir generar
nuevas dinámicas aquellos espacios
flexibles donde se fomente la
colaboración
donde te inspires donde puedas conectar
donde puedas dialogar con las personas y
te ayuden a pensar en esas ciudades
posibles en esas ciudades que todos
hemos imaginado
imaginemos estos proyectos como esas
células detonadoras que pueden generar
una sinergia positiva en su entorno
inmediato ese efecto de los vidrios
rotos pero a la inversa
gracias
[Aplausos]